une production du studio SF
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut que nous
inviter dans cette ph-cantin avec moi
Dom plante cette semaine sur le port
cette semaine c'est une semaine bien
spéciale parce qu'on reçoit une de mes
meilleures amies sinon ma meilleure amie
en fait rien à voir avec qui je fais de
la musique depuis longtemps depuis en
fait que depuis les débuts de Ariane roi
le projet musical
on a enregistré des tonnes ensemble et
en studio je fais je joue avec elle en
tournée aussi de la guitare d'abeilles
de recevoir quelqu'un que je connais
autant qui est aussi proche on a raconté
des des histoires bien des signes des
musiques de parler de d'en fait de toute
son parcours de ses débuts
c'est arrivé son premier show jusqu'à
aujourd'hui sont épais son album on a
parlé de création à cloud d'écriture pH
il était convaincu là je suis convaincu
qui peut pas chanter puis moi je dis
qu'il peut chanter on a eu des bas là
dessus c'est pas une question de pouvoir
vous passer de bien faire
vous-même monsieur dans notre
conversation
non
puis on a philosophie aussi un peu à
faim
ça
philosophe ça s'en va loin mais c'est
cool c'est stimulant et vraiment
personne pétillante allumée une personne
incroyable que j'aime vraiment beaucoup
profondément
la conversation fait que pas l'écoute
bon pas de caste le podcast aujourd'hui
est présenté par menscape manscape vous
le savez c'est une de nos compagnies
préférées qui sont avec nous même depuis
tellement longtemps depuis tellement
longtemps qu'il nous supporte puis on
les supporte aussi puis il y a toutes
sortes de produits pour les soins
destinés principalement aux hommes que
ce soit pour sentir bon pour tailler sa
pilosité ou pour même des boxeurs il y a
vraiment des produits de tous types
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
plus grande qui permet de ramasser plus
de poils en moins de passage je fais que
c'est vraiment l'obgrade d'un outil déjà
incroyable on a un code promo pour vous
vous le connaissez mais continuez à
l'utiliser le sans filtre 20% de rabais
livraison gratuite sur tous les produits
manscape allez voir ça puis merci à vous
de nous encourager par la barre
d'encourager mais ce que merci merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis content
[Rires]
beaucoup de temps pour ensemble quand
même il fallait voir
comment ça va me fout bien ça
je suis stressé parce que je trouve que
j'ai
réalisé que que parler et m'écouter
parler après en fait je le fais jamais
mais je trouve c'est compliqué je trouve
c'est difficile j'ai la misère à peu
parler vite aussi le choix attention
j'ai fait ça avec des entrevues des fois
j'ai fait qu'est-ce qui se passe non
ma musique
mais c'est drôle que tu dis ça parce que
dernièrement j'ai quand même écouter les
premières tonnes que j'ai sorties sur un
mon EP avant l'album
ouais c'est un bon exercice
de l'acceptation en même temps ça fait
comme quand même beaucoup de 50 qui est
sorti c'est juste trois ans
mais en même temps de voir l'évolution
de voir que je suis plus là puis en même
temps d'être comme un peu attendri puis
assez Ariane début 20 et 19 20 ans que
je l'acceptais différemment je
l'appréciais différemment ça c'est une
bonne expérience
à ruinranda en tournée à l'horizontale
vietnamien
[Rires]
puis il y a d'autres qui a joué Charlie
tu étais je l'ai vu dans ta face il y
avait un petit inconfort quand même
c'est un moment
ouais le moment que tu t'entends en fait
tu t'entends chanter tu t'entends mais
attends moi ça m'est arrivé ça m'invite
ça met en place l'oreiller à Québec là
j'entends une de mes chansons puis je la
place Lorie si tout le monde c'est
encore lisse évidemment
ton affaire à toi sauf que tu en penses
tu es comme si bizarre écouter c'est
cette chanson là dans ce contexte là si
je suis comme je reviens Simon parce que
au plus de monde possible des inconnus
de parler devant une conversation puis
j'entends ma chanson c'est comme puis
voilà
mais comme ça m'arrivait souvent ça
m'arrive pas souvent mais quand ça
arrive c'est bon c'est toujours bizarre
quand même débile que ça t'arrive c'est
dans le sens c'est fou là je me rappelle
ça me fait penser juste un petit Grégory
Charles sorti son album avec
des sorties il y avait dit genre
il y avait dit Oh chaque fois que je
l'entends je peux pas m'empêcher
d'arrêter dans l'épicerie puis genre
je m'imaginais genre tu es comme à
l'épicerie cage
à Richard qui chante sa profondeur il
est tellement contente
de fierté tu sais comme
[Rires]
ils sont plus grands genre non mais one
fan lui-même c'est ça je trouve ça que
je suis parti sur un jardin
de Grégory Charles que j'ai sur l'idée
sur l'île Charles
on le voit maintenant au Québec puis
c'est comme le gars que l'oreille
absolue qui est comme il donne les
commentaires tellement tout le temps
précis puis quand même un sur ces sur
les artistes qui donnent le meilleur
d'eux puis la meilleure tonne qui a fait
c'est thank of you
comme de bizarre
dans ces convictions sa vision
artistique là
on a des opinions
tranchant quand même et je trouve c'est
drôle que genre son kite son calendcard
pour comme en or ce soit Tink of you qui
est comme c'est lui genre le juge qui
coupe le monde c'est lui qui a cassé
aux gens
de dire qu'est-ce qui est bon ce qui est
bon en anglais en plus ce qu'on fait
comprendre c'est que ça prend justement
ton ton gros Bagneux d'envie puis après
ça tout est permis
les intrépides puis après ça tu as le
droit de dire ce que tu veux sur des
jeunes artistes incroyable Grégory
mais bref oui c'est ça le pays mais pour
venir à ça c'est drôle quand même tes
tantôt ça fait 5 ans ça fait 3 ans puis
3 ans c'est comme pas long dans le fond
c'est pas un long moment mais on dirait
que ça fait une éternité depuis ce
temps-là mettons les premières tonnes tu
sais qu'on a enregistré que tu as sorti
les premiers shows
je me rappelle on s'était croisé dans le
sous-sol dans le studio à Québec puis tu
étais là que ta guide puis ça faisait
pas longtemps que vous étiez rencontré
c'est les débuts de tout ça puis c'est
fou pareil parce que tu sais
on s'est rencontré puis je veux dire tu
avais sorti zéro tonne non
à toutes les étapes
pas genre une première tonne à
Jean-Pierre ok il y a du monde qui
est le notre vie
toutes les étapes puis c'est quand même
je serai quand même fouille
ça fait un peu plus d'un an un an et
quelques mois
juste depuis le temps cette année-là
puis en même temps je pense assez
puisser au final j'ai commencé à écrire
mes tunes en 2017 parce qu'en fait je
m'étais inscrite un genre de il y a
comme l'ampli à Québec rempli volet pro
qui est comme ça
la première étape dans Photoshop mais
c'est ça je me suis inscrite au volley
pro puis c'est vrai parce que j'étais en
train de faire mon bac à l'université
puis
j'étais un peu en train de paniquer
parce que tu sais quand tu es où
j'étudiant en musique en jazz à
l'Université Laval puis il y a un moment
je pense quand tu fais ton bac il faut
comme commencer aussi à faire autre
chose que juste avant l'école on en
parlant cette semaine en ce sens que Ben
de plus en plus des gens commencent à
Giger des fois c'est un des guides
corporate moi j'ai fait des choses je
vais jouer une fois par semaine au Bâton
Rouge maintenant
quelques années
c'est juste pour le Cholet il est là le
piment
pour se mettre qui se met danser
quand même un passage obligé de Guiguet
ce genre d'endroit là où est-ce que les
gens sont pas nécessairement là pour
écouter
c'est vraiment c'est beaucoup j'ai
l'impression que j'associe ça plus au
passage scolaire des fois on a
l'impression que
ça commence par le puis il y a vraiment
des gens qui restent dans ces branches
là qui sont vraiment bon là-dedans puis
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour ceux
parce que c'est extrêmement pas facile
c'est quand même un gros défi B en fait
toi tu le sais trop longtemps
recto-verso
c'est correct qui va dans ce que tu es
tellement plus d'expérience tu sais que
c'est aujourd'hui mais je veux dire il y
a plein parcours différents j'ai des
amis qui ont pas du tout passé par là
mais j'en ai fait pas tant que ça non
plus mais c'est juste qu'à un moment
donné j'avais juste envie de jouer en
fait peu importe déjà c'est important
que je sorte de de l'univers quelque
chose de l'école j'étais en un moment
donné puis le je me suis quand même
inscrite à l'ampli volet pro mais je me
suis inscrite j'avais pas de tonnes je
me suis vraiment psychologue exposé
comme avoir une idée de projet des gens
qui vont là pour avoir des sous-titres
c'est comme un ampli volet pro sédument
heureux mais aussi c'est aussi un fond
financier comme pour aider
puis moi j'avais j'avais rien à ce
moment-là puis j'ai fait toi let's go
mais ça signifie que l'année d'après
dans le deal c'est qu'elle était d'après
tu fais un show Festival d'été déjà
écrit une chanson je fais la chanson
j'ai des prix mais il fallait dans ma
dernière année de bac je compose un show
de mes chansons
[Musique]
que j'ai beaucoup de monde et
normalement qui vont bien installer
vraiment vite en même temps mais c'est
allé en effet très vite mais ça fait
quand même et ça commence en 2017 c'est
juste que moi au départ j'étais vraiment
lente c'est drôle parce que la première
rencontre que j'ai eu avec deux j'avais
demandé de filmer un vidéo un live
session que j'avais fait dans ce temps
là
il y avait ton drone qui jouait de
l'abeille on s'est rencontré puis elle
m'a engagé pour mes services de
vidéastes
de la vidéo c'est comme entre autres
genre à chaque année une fois par année
je mens et je dis que je fais de la
vidéo puis je fais un contrôle puis ça
finit là mais je fais pas d'idées
puis genre les extraits qui mettaient
c'était ça qui date de 2018 qui est
genre une tonne qui est jamais sorti
elle avait des clips genre carrément
débile c'est qu'une poule sa tête des
costumes de gens
en fait
c'est ça les vidéos clips sont quand
même bon mais la direction photo sur ce
vidéo clip là
je le vois puis je me mets à danser
[Rires]
[Musique]
je continue à faire ça puis c'est juste
deux moments qui me comme écrit vieux
parce qu'il m'avait tu es devenu voir le
chaud festival l'été c'est drôle parce
que tu avais comme tu avais tu étais
comment c'est bon mais
j'avais l'impression que tu étais avec
bon ça pouvait être meilleur hein c'est
un peu c'est un peu ça ton approche là
puis dans le sens que tu avais raison je
peux je sais pas je t'avais dit il y a
pas vraiment d'arrangement
non mais c'était comme tout le monde
jouait les bons accords c'est tout le
monde quand même
hein il y a pas c'est comme il y a pas
de souci
c'est vraiment vrai mais ça sert à rien
non mais tu sais puis moi je suis sur
j'hésitais encore je sais pas pourquoi
j'avais j'arrivais pas à me lancer pour
vrai puis on est ici tu m'avais dit ton
intérêt puis tu m'avais juste écrit Ayo
en fait
qu'on fasse une tonne pour être pour
être le fun mais genre qu'on essaie
mettons c'est une des rares fois que
j'ai
que j'ai été quelque chose
je rends pas un têtu j'aille seul aussi
mettons quelqu'un qui que j'aime ce
qu'il fait une colère
genre j'ai jamais eu laisser les choses
venir puis les choses arriveront mais
Ariane c'est une des une des seuls que
j'ai testé
[Rires]
à composer c'est quoi ce processus là de
composition parce que tu avais-tu c'est
des fois avoir des restreintes
temporelles fait que moi des contraintes
temporelles se fait que tu es obligé de
prendre des choix créatifs qui sinon
viendraient pas à toi mais toi est-ce
que ça leur fait ça puis comment est-ce
que tu le gérer puis est-ce que les
parce qu'il est quand même aussi toute
l'aspect texte qui est assez recherché
de dans ta musique puis comment tu le
fais ça
les 10 chansons que j'ai composé cette
année-là il y en a aucune qui existe
maintenant
que c'était
c'était pas bon
j'avais 19 ans mais
genre non mais genre de beginning years
le plus c'est comme des Toons genre
version démo qui sont jamais sortis
pas bon mais je dirais que c'est sur la
contrainte de temps ça fait que j'ai
écrit mais j'avais beaucoup
moi j'ai réalisé ça dans ma vie de
travailleur autonome parce que j'ai
réalisé que j'étais j'étais fou une
bonne étudiante moi à l'école j'étais
vraiment j'ai fonctionné super bien avec
un corps scolaire ce qui rend pas pour
tout le monde surtout en ordre
mais moi ça ça marchait genre j'avais
dit bonheur j'ai étudié je t'ai acheté
j'étais quand même une
bonne élève puis ramasser dans le dans
le monde de tu fais un peu ton horaire
c'est toi qu'il faut qu'il fasse que
ta vie dans ce que moi je suis ma propre
bosse je suis pas content d'ailleurs
mais ça a mis quand même j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment difficile au début puis en même
temps d'avoir c'est pour ça que je te
parle de deadlines parce que au moins
d'avoir ce cadre-là ça fait en sorte que
j'étais comme c'est sûr je vais y
arriver parce que si j'ai quelque chose
à remettre j'ai trop de voix c'est sûr
c'est sûr et certain mais après ça quand
j'ai quitté l'université et j'ai pas eu
tellement une drop j'ai trouvé ça trop
dur de dire que je m'essaye comme
essayer de vivre la musique parce que
j'étais quand même tout le temps congé
en même temps je suis jamais en congé il
faut tout le temps que parce que tu es
au début je serais jamais votre
spectacle et je montais mon enfer c'est
un peu drôle de dire ouais mais en ce
moment j'écris mais tout au final c'est
seulement deux maintenant c'est ce que
je fais je fais des spectacles puis je
vais faire du studio je vais composer
mais de gueiji montant là-dedans puis de
pas sentir que des fois je suis
complètement paresseuse à juste et je
sais pas quoi faire de ma vie je
comprends paralysé par le stress parce
que j'ai pas une structure claire ou au
contraire on a l'impression que j'arrête
jamais de travailler parce qu'en fait
j'ai jamais de repos montage je pense
juste à ça moi je suis encore en train
d'essayer de
m'arranger dans ce cadre-là que je
trouve vraiment compliqué des moments où
que cette année que j'avais l'impression
que j'étais proche d'être complètement
épuisé puis d'autres fois que quand
j'arrive chez nous tout seul avec des
jours libres devant moi et ma vie avait
aucun sens
par la même
processus c'est quand j'étais mettons au
cégep genre mon horaire genre j'étais
comme une machine type genre dans le
cadre et puis mettons
cégep souvent en Europe plus chargée qui
mettent en université c'est plus de
couple factice jean-marine était était
toujours pareil
cours dès que j'avais des moments off je
suis presque genre toutes les soirs tort
ou cégep je revenais c'était toujours
après jour puis je me demandais jamais
mettons justement qu'est-ce que je fais
aujourd'hui parce que c'était tout le
temps genre au corps de taux puis genre
les midis
tout était placé et puis après ça à
l'université ça a comme commencé à être
un petit peu moins solide parce que il
est un peu moins de cours puis je
commençais à jouer le soir coucher tard
des fois il faut d'une colle le matin et
puis là c'était comme moi régulier puis
même à faire quand j'ai fini
l'université au début je pense que c'est
peut-être un genre de très d'été les
deux on est pas TDA mais pas loin mais
on le sait puis genre je pense que
de ce que j'en sais je pense que les
gens mettent des trous d'attention ou tu
sais les gens qui ont ces gens ce genre
de traits là
fonctionne mieux dans des dans des
cordes de même parce que parce que ça
les structures puis que ça les
structure un peu externe qui vient plus
facile que de se créer sa propre
structure moi aussi j'étais des années
mettons après l'université quand j'avais
beaucoup de choses mais c'est tout mais
j'en étais différent parce que là une
journée qui est une journée c'était leur
journée enfin
j'ai jamais rien qui régulier jamais
genre de journée qui se rassemble puis
j'étais tout le temps aussi tu sais en
dehors de mais là j'ai du temps puis là
j'étais tout le temps un peu en train de
travailler mais aussi un peu en train de
perdre mon temps tout le temps et puis
genre quand je prenne du temps off je me
sentais mal de pas travailler mais il
faut que j'étais comme jamais mon
cerveau tu es comme jamais genre quelle
heure je travaille ou là je te repos
mais attends c'est tout le temps puis ça
a vraiment été long avant que je
retrouve une genre de
de structures en fait le mettons ça fait
vraiment une structure plus plus claire
que là je me sens comme quand j'étais au
cégep performant mettons puis rigoureux
c'est genre depuis que mettons avec
Julia
[Musique]
je sais que je m'envole je m'envoie au
studio je travaille tout à l'heure à
telle heure chez nous je vais mettre ma
journée c'est cool puis là on dirait
un genre de mode qui à chaque jour on
accomplit des trucs c'est qu'on avance
quand même j'ai l'impression que tu es
capable de prendre des moments de repos
ou c'est la danse d'une structure même
dans ton équilibre de vie tu travailles
vraiment beaucoup mais ça aussi et ça
fait partie de ça va aussi quand
s'arrêter puis essayer de doser mais
c'est clair si je veux dire
moi aussi c'est qu'il y a quelque chose
de bizarre des fois dans dans le travail
de exemple je me disais qui c'était même
je veux bon faut que j'avance comme que
je vais avoir écrit je vais avoir
composé un peu j'avais fait avancer
telle musique tel texte Forever mais des
fois que tu travailles tellement fort
dans une journée puis que tu finis ta
journée de hauteur un résultat c'est
vraiment dur d'être comme en mode ok
c'est super concret mais ton j'avance
j'ai tellement faux j'ai senti que j'ai
l'impression que je saignais puis que
c'est fou le teuf de de rester motivé
dans le sens de
d'avoir l'impression que ça a un sens
qu'est-ce que je fais c'est puis en même
temps je sais que c'est ça avec toute la
reconnaissance de cheveux en fait je
suis vraiment quelqu'un parce que je
peux vivre maintenant la musique c'est
un énorme privilège dans le paysage la
musique en ce moment tu sais mais c'est
en fait la période de ma vie où j'ai
l'impression que j'avais plus
l'impression de depuis que je peux vous
études de travailler puis que il y avait
une rigueur une structure puis qui avait
comme je sais pas un but à chaque jour
c'est quand vous allez l'album puisqu'on
faisait comme tous les jours c'est à
l'automne 2021 si on se voyait quasiment
tous les jours au studio puis quand tu
travailles en équipe même s'il y a des
moins bonne journée c'est vraiment
facile de se motiver puis de dire à qui
on a quand même avancé ça puis dans
l'impression que
le plus fier dans ma vie parce que parce
que c'est mais voilà ça c'est un gros
combat encore fait souvent je me dis si
je suis plus jeune donc oui ça ressemble
quand même
le tien ça ça a le beaucoup de trait en
commun avec l'entrepreneuriat parce que
dans le fond c'était un business puis
moi je veux dire je peux pas parler de
mon expérience
d'artiste mais mon expérience en tant
qu'entrepreneur c'est exactement ça
c'est comme ok il y a des jours où
est-ce que tu réponds à deux emails puis
il y a comme rien qui se passe
ça avance pas mes affaires la business
marche pas parce que il y a rien qui se
passe puis il y a des jours que tu finis
pas de travailler sur un million de
cassettes tu as dans une journée tu sais
tout le temps en vacances tu es jamais
en vacances c'est vraiment ça puis
l'album ça revient comme quand tu lances
un nouveau projet tu sais qu'un tu as
besoin de travailler sur quelque chose
c'est ici au studio des fois on a fait
des semaines que ça arrêtait pas quand
on était en place quelque chose
maintenant on a un nouveau système où
elle veut que je peux comprendre c'est
quoi parce que j'ai l'impression que
beaucoup de similitudes à faire là mais
vraiment mais ça vient avec la famille
avec ce que tu le veuilles ou pas par
exemple
c'est comme je disais moi je suis
supposé mettons Jerry bien mes finances
et donne avec mes impôts pendant toute
mon affaire et dans le sens que c'est
des trucs que j'apprends aussi je me
laisse une chance si je me dis OK dans
le sens je gère vraiment aller puis en
fait je dis ça j'ai une équipe
mon gérant sont des personnes incroyable
qui sont pour essayer de moins possible
je suis fucking chanteuse mais je veux
dire c'est ça moi c'est c'est vraiment
c'est ma bête noire
mais c'est il y a aussi le fait que
cette année c'est une année de de chaud
parce que justement on est lancé l'album
en février fait qu'on fait beaucoup de
choses puis vous auriez c'était comme un
horaire assez intense dans les derniers
mois c'est une grosse année puis là
éventuellement je sais qu'il faut que je
me remette à penser bon il va avoir un
deuxième album il faut que je recommence
à être
j'ai trouvé j'ai eu un hiver quand même
j'ai trouvé ça dur c'est super parce que
j'avais l'impression que j'étais un peu
je prenais le temps de d'intégrer tout
ce qui venait se passer parce que dans
la dernière année en fait les choses
sont allés plus vite que je pensais à
une vitesse incroyable quand même en
même temps peut c'est pas un affaire
faisait carrément de fou à échelle mais
mais pour moi qui est quand même dans la
lenteur et dans et dans un moment de
solitude j'ai besoin de calme j'ai
besoin de full introspection c'est juste
c'est beaucoup à la fois puis de
commencer la danse de continuer à faire
des choses de commencer à écrire en
parallèle je me rendais compte que ça
fonctionnait pas c'est pire il y a un
moment aussi qu'il faut que je vive des
choses ou que je gobe genre il faut que
je vive
pour pour avoir des choses à dire que ce
soit moins vraiment intéressant puis à
m'emmener
je donne de la même spectacle depuis
beaucoup de temps si je me rendais
compte que
je peux pas j'ai besoin d'un espace
mental j'ai besoin de d'une coupure en
fait si j'essaie quand même de le faire
mais mais ça ça comme été deux accepté
pour moi parce que justement j'étais
comme un voyant j'ai tout en libre si
genre d'ailleurs puis vas-y écrit mais
en même temps mais c'est correct de
continuer puis de le faire puis de
garder une rigueur puis je veux dire des
fois des fois j'en ai composé quand même
un peu mais
ouais moi j'ai tout le temps
l'impression que tout est à recommencé
dans ma compréhension de mon processus
c'est quand je me fais souvent demandé
ça c'est quoi ton processus de création
puisque je sais pas
genre ça change tout le temps c'est
toujours à refaire puis j'ai tout le
temps raison que je dois réapprendre
comment écrire un texte comment écrire
la musique genre c'est comme tout le
temps je commence par vous si ça vient
pas de faut que ça vienne un élan faut
que ça vienne j'ai un coup de cœur
musical ok moi
j'ai pas encore
stand avec une formule c'est là que ça
devient moins intéressant je pense là
une méthode de faire
ça puis que ça donne une tonne on le
ferait plus scientifique la formule
formule bac il y avait une formule là
formule ça fait des hits mais mais c'est
ça
je pense que c'est normal
de toujours je pense à commencer au
départ
aussi je pense que c'est le travail
ici dans une journée
à louer du temps à écrire
dans ce moment-là plus important c'est
le temps le temps que tu as lu à ça puis
même si finalement tu n'aurais rien
écrit mais que peut-être écouter de la
musique pour t'inspirer ou quelque chose
ben tout ça en magasin puis ça va
ressortir plus tard en année maintenant
exact ça c'est sûr
je pense pas tout le temps non non mais
j'attends que les dieux me parle et je
veux dire si on comprend que ça prend
pas juste mais genre c'est mon dieu mais
je veux savoir
des fois du temps consacrer à
l'inspiration l'inspiration ou justement
pour écrire ça peut être juste aussi va
va marcher dehors va lire un livre dans
le sens prend ce temps-là qui te donner
c'est un gros luxe que j'ai parce que
j'ai ce temps là j'ai la chance qu'en
fait je j'ai pas besoin justement
d'aller travailler au McDo toute la
journée parce que justement dans le sens
que
si c'est un luxe puis des fois je suis
pas nécessairement obligé de faire ce
que je pense que je dois faire si je
veux dire je peux aussi vivre puis de
cette peut-être que le lendemain c'est
là que ça se passe mieux mais c'est pour
moi c'est aussi un enjeu de pas me
sentir coupable
de ces moments-là puis de c'est le
mettons le temps si je recommencer un
peu à écrire si je t'avais parlé que ton
projet tu m'avais dit en fait
dans deux semaines je vais en studio
puis là j'aimerais ça dans composer
d'autres d'ici là
mais c'est ça fait que j'ai recommencé à
écrire et puis là je me mets une genre
de discipline qui mettons souvent le
matin
avant que comme la journée on commence
puis que là on a des trucs où il y a des
courriels qui rentrent mais genre je me
mets là dessus et puis bon j'écris
mettez dès que je fais dès que
je pue en mode dès que j'oublie que je
t'entraîne de décrire
mon ordi
en fait dès que je tombe dans mes
automatismes j'ouvre internet genre
j'ouvre Facebook
souvent je lis un peu parce que souvent
je veux juste lire le matin il y a un
mot je lis un mot puis ce mot-là me
donne une idée j'ai quelque chose qui a
aucun rapport ce que je disais mais
genre bref mais
dès que je suis consciemment en train
dès que je tombe dans mes réflexes puis
là une fois que tu tombes dans facebook
je veux dire toute créativité tout
inspiration
c'est la mort de la créativité ça craque
le disais
non mais c'est fou
dans un genre de quelque chose tu avais
une réflexion avec amorcé plus genre te
remets en le genre d'état de deux
zombies puis des gens ok
intéressant
que justement tu tombes dans un ok je
vois ce que les 30 secondes et ça prend
pas de temps que
faut
étudier pour un gros examen dernièrement
puis c'était vraiment beaucoup d'études
une technique qui est pas mal bon à
appliquer j'essaie de l'appliquer de
plus en plus dans comme mon travail qui
est de 30 minutes ou est-ce que tu
touches arrière
avec toi tu as même pas le droit de le
regarder tu as pas le droit d'ouvrir tu
as pas le droit d'aller sur un autre
page tu as pas le droit à faire autre
chose que te concentres à ton truc 5
minutes off ou est-ce que le tu t'en vas
te manger tu prends ton ciel des
affaires je continue le même temps aussi
longtemps que tu as besoin de le faire
technique
ce que tu dis
aucune cloche
mais moi quand je le fais je suis
capable de le faire ça marche bien quand
même
mais après c'est sûr c'est sûr que ça
aide aussi puis ça pourrait être aussi à
Yport et
des albums puis on prend le temps de le
faire c'est tout le temps c'est sûr par
contre c'est prendre le temps de
s'arrêter puis de changer de disque de
pas rester ce que j'ai sur un affaire
aussi puis mais ouais il y a quelque
chose de cool quand même dans
comment
carrière de
compositrice a commencé ou de d'autrices
si on veut
s'il y a des artistes qui arrivent en
sur le devant le public dans le fond qui
sont qui naissent devant le public avec
un emmagasinage de tonnes qui ont fait
au cours de 15 ans mettons le type le
carré avec leur premier album avec voici
le best of des 300 tonnes que j'ai écrit
dans le dernier j'ai commencé à écrire
plus il arrive avec ça pour le premier
album tout le monde fait genre cet album
l'étape absolument débile parce que
c'est débile c'est l'artiste est bon
c'est un best of d'un artiste qui est
bon
à composer je compose j'apprends à
composer un composant dans le fond oui
c'est ça
qui sont plus assez bonnes pour
l'artiste que je suis devenu
m'améliorant en composant encore plus là
qui continue à composer là un P qui est
non qui est là on continue à apprendre à
composer en composant là l'album arrive
effectivement je trouve que c'est un
processus qui est comme sur le long
terme qui m'apparaît comme quand même
intéressant pour une carrière qui va
continuer à quelqu'un on s'améliore on
s'améliore on s'améliore on s'améliore
on s'améliore c'est quand même cool mais
souvent en fait c'est que c'est pour les
premières albums les gens font vraiment
le best of justement de toutes les
tonnes qui ont écrit comme tu dis leur
adolescence là c'est après ça c'est sûr
que ben tu as pas le choix tu écris des
nouvelles choses
moi comme j'avais fait mon EP avant
c'est le premier album c'était donc que
des chansons que j'avais composé dans
les deux dernières années puis c'est
drôle parce que ça va tellement vite par
contre c'est deux ans pour écrire dans
un sketch il faut un album ça me prendra
pas six mois évidemment c'est que ça
prend ça prend du temps mais ça va vite
dans le sens où j'ai si je disais ça
moins un peu tantôt c'est comme la moi
début 20 ans mais
j'écoute j'ai écouté justement bah en
fait je chante mon album mettons à
toutes les semaines puis il y a quand
même je me sens loin de ça des jeux puis
ça fait un an qui est sorti puis c'est
pas en terme de si je suis fière de ce
qu'on a faite puis je reconnais le fait
que déjà je pense que je suis ailleurs
déjà il y a des textes qui me parlent
moins déjà des textes que je sais qui
vont au contraire durer dans ma vie dans
le sens que je veux quand même regarder
tout le temps dans différemment puis la
perception te change par rapport à des
textes et je veux dire des fois tu même
si c'est ce que toi-même tu as écrit tu
le reçois différemment puisque toi te
composer tu es des trucs qui me
rejoignent juste moins puis c'est
correct je pense que il faut l'accepter
puis
ça c'est quand même un privilège que
j'ai d'avoir pu composer des chansons
dans deux ans qui vont rester là c'est
comme c'est une genre de journal intime
quoi que je livre mettons au monde puis
que l'enfant pour le meilleur pour le
pays mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est des années de ma vie c'est des
années qui représentent aussi ce que je
suis en train de vivre maintenant puis
après ça on passe à autre chose puisque
moi j'ai dû faire la paix avec ça parce
que parce que moi les chansons en
général je les écrivent deux semaines
après je veux les jeter et que là si tu
sors un album mais Tony m'appartiennent
plus c'est un grand soulagement pour moi
parce qu'on dirait que j'ai vraiment
l'archiprise un bon exercice de juste ok
c'est bon
ça me fait rire parce que le nombre de
fois qu'on a eu des tas qui mettons déjà
assez
qu'on aimerait mettre l'album j'étais
comme non non on a tous les bonnes c'est
juste que tu es juste pu exciter parce
que tu viens pas plus juste la composer
quand tu le composé puis qu'on le fait
les premières fois on sautait dans le
studio tellement qu'on tripesse contre
ça malade aussi de cette tête là parce
que les gens qui vont l'écouter pour la
première fois ben ils vont peut-être on
espère que il y a moins de découvrir
au début permanent c'est sûr que la même
tonne justement la tienne d'un autre de
l'écoute 250 fois malgré tout
exact mais heureusement que c'était le
pour ça mais non parce que j'en sortirai
pas dans l'album genre ça c'est ça
marcherait pas puis tu sais après c'est
je
tant mieux si genre je vais évoluer
encore dans la musique puis tant mieux
si j'ai je j'espère que j'ai un peu de
choses à dire encore puis que ça va être
meilleur c'est ça qu'on l'idéal comme
aussi le processus s'y mettons de avant
ça ne faites beaucoup de démo des tonnes
pendant comme une longue période avant
d'aller en studio les réenregistré puis
le les retravailler encore après mais
c'est toute cette période là justement
où qu'on faisait des maquettes des
tonnes au fur et à mesure que tu es
composé
ben c'était quand même une longue durée
de temps ce qui fait que
on est passé par plein de phases mettons
de s'il y a des tonnes qui mettons à
manitailler des tonnes que dans l'album
ça chante puis dire ok ça c'est une
tonne que c'est clairement dans Charles
béton
d'avoir plusieurs phases à l'intérieur
finalement c'est l'album c'est un peu
aussi un
amalgame de plusieurs phases de
qui pendant un bouton basé sur une
affaire
mais il y a beaucoup d'artistes qui
fonctionnent
il se donne un concept préalablement un
enfant ce qui partent avec une direction
vraiment précise avant même d'avoir
commencé à composer puis j'ai déjà
essayé de faire ça puis je pense que je
suis pas la candidate pour ceux c'est
comme si ça se passe quand je le fais
les choses les choses vont vraiment plus
se définir mettons pendant que j'en crée
ou je sais pas mettons justement moi
j'arrivais des fois j'ai deux mais j'ai
écouté une tonneau dans le short puisque
maquille genre on part de ce bid de
Drôme le mettre donc ça
me représente même d'envie je la misère
des fois faire des plans full d'avance
je suis bien baisse spontané là c'est
fun c'est moins une fois mais il y a
quelque chose qui j'ai pas envie de me
restreindre suite à ça puis j'ai pas
j'ai pas envie non plus de me projeter à
ce point-là tout de suite puis en même
temps je comprends vraiment pourquoi
quelqu'un veut faire ça typiquement puis
je pense que en général ça peut vraiment
donner des affaires incroyables mais ça
aura des bruits des comptes en fait
ça le pot de de faire un projet pour le
moment qu'il va être qui va être
cohérent artistiquement il faut avoir
une ligne directrice qui va avoir un son
album ça le contre justement il y a
mamie mais si tu es plus là
c'est ici pendant le processus et puis
là tu es plus là puis je pense aussi que
rapidement trop de restriction aussi ça
peut ça peut mais on sous-estime une
fois que la cohérence a vient de toi si
je veux dire je suis la personne qui la
chante je suis la personne qui fait les
tunes dans une période de temps qui est
pas non plus pendant 15 ans tu sais je
veux dire nécessairement je suis dans
une pause de ma vie j'ai une façon de
dire les choses à ce moment-là je suis
entouré avec les mêmes musiciens il y a
quelque chose de ça reste que c'est tout
le temps le filtre de toutes les
décisions que tu prends c'est tout le
temps ton goût là le goût de l'artiste
puis de les gens qui rêvent autour mais
tu sais tout le temps ce même filtre là
il va tout le temps avoir des limitateur
comme un je pense à travers un album
mettons parce que c'est ça reste que ça
a passé à travers le filtre Ariane puis
tu sais faire une tonne c'est
10000 décisions un million de décisions
tout le temps à chaque fois
non mais tu es sur toutes les les
décisions de son de mix des mots de tout
ça
[Musique]
t'appliques ton ton goût à toi FACTIVE
au final ça ne peut qu'aître
cohérent et un reflet de toit mais toi
qui est multiples parce qu'on est tout
on est tous multiples on est tous
plusieurs facettes plusieurs avec qu'on
aille plusieurs sons
c'est de pas tomber dans le centre de
lire le je te parlais de un livre de
Rick Robin sur la créativité
c'est bien des autres comme les enfants
ce que c'est pas hyper concret technique
c'est vraiment ces réflexions sur la
création de l'image à très à son image
exacte puis
même j'ai dit ça beaucoup en entrevue au
départ quand je sortais l'album c'est le
j'essaie vraiment de de faire comme je
voulais puis de pas me restreindre puis
de vraiment de suivre tout le temps
jusqu'au bout ce que je pense que j'ai
fait à ce moment-là puisqu'on a fait
ensemble c'est vraiment mais après ça
d'avoir pris conscience de on a tous des
croyances artistiques on est toutes dans
des cercles hermétiques ou non avec des
gens de on a comme une idée d'un son
d'une esthétique d'un tong qu'est-ce qui
est bon qu'est-ce qu'il est pas c'est
bon je pense que c'est vraiment bon
d'être
je pense que je le suis aussi mais je me
suis sentiments des fois j'entendais
comme des voix de soi de ma mère qui
allait l'écouter ou de mon ami qui
allait coûter ma musique et puis qu'elle
est qu'est-ce qu'elle va penser de ça et
tout puis j'ai remarqué que c'est bien
plus présent que ce que je pensais des
fois quand j'étais au départ de quelque
chose puisque en fait je réussis souvent
aboutir à une chanson quand justement
c'est comme ok là on met ça de côté mais
ce travail-là de partir avec un esprit
de débutant puis d'être un peu comme
mindset d'enfant qui est comme un c'est
que ça fait si je fais ça que ça fait si
maintenant je fais une tonne et country
mais que les gens M'associent pas à du
country je pense c'est par exemple
là-dedans mais moi j'ai tout le temps
peur de m'enfermer dans ce que je pense
que je suis puis dans ce que les autres
pensent que je suis aussi puis ça je
trouve que c'est un piège je veux pas je
veux pas comme éviter moi-même je pense
qu'à m'en donner même
j'ai des tendances j'ai des j'ai des
élans puis faut que je les suivis
mais trop mais je sais pas c'est pas
tant que classe
de
se faire confiance
à son propre jugement puis tu sais ce
que tu disais de d'avoir la voix de
quelqu'un un projet de toi ou la voix de
ton ami qu'est-ce que mon ami penserait
à cet homme là c'est pas vraiment ça la
question c'est comme faut vraiment que
tu fasses confiance à ton instinct et
puis à l'instant aussi des gens
je pense que c'est une des forces
vraiment là c'est quoi savoir ce que tu
aimes ce que tu veux ce que tu veux pas
quand même assez clairement tu es quand
même un instant quand même vraiment fort
tu sais
moi je me souviens au début ça ça
m'avait quand même
surpris marquer le thé à quel point
mettons
à l'époque tu avais 19-20 ans mais genre
tu étais comme ok non ça c'est vraiment
bon ça c'est de la merde dans la nature
c'est vraiment pas tout le monde que ce
non c'est ça que cette capacité là
que c'est vraiment pas si clair pour eux
puis le devant
je sais pas qui il y a un je sais pas
qui peut être bon parce que c'est pas
tout le temps mais
je pense que quand même que
cette instinct qui est quand même fort
de genre ça va ou tu t'en vas c'est
aussi
parce que tu étais là puis que j'ai
l'impression quand quelqu'un est le je
pense que tu me laisses vraiment
beaucoup l'espace pour le faire puis que
juste sentir que mon opinion était la
bienvenue et que je chantais tout de
suite que c'est ce que j'ai à dire
c'était pas nécessairement il y a des
gens dans le fond dans vie qui qui te
laissent pas nécessairement de l'espace
puis bon tu t'es jamais tu es un peu
intimidé puis j'avais pas senti ça fait
que c'est plus facile de le faire des
fois être avec d'autres personnes ou à
être toute seule c'est pire parce que là
il y a un truc qu'on a pas parlé mais je
pense que c'est pertinent à parler parce
que c'est
le témoin mettons on parle de commencer
de travailler ensemble puis que tu avais
déjà tu avais déjà
un goût musical qui était développé vous
avez déjà un instinct puis que c'était
commencé à écrire des tonnes à 17 ans
puis que ça a commencé le mais mettons
pour les gens qui nous écoutent mettons
quelqu'un qui voudrait commencer à faire
de la musique et écrire
[Musique]
le nombre de tonnes que tu as appris le
nombre de de chaude secondaire que tu as
fait le nombre de choses tout ça rentre
dans le bagage aussi qui était arrivé
justement quand tu es né en tant
qu'artiste la musicienne existait quand
même depuis longtemps c'est vrai ça
amène une confiance
clairement parce que moi les enfants de
ma vie c'est mes clausées
de commencer avec ça puis des
puis d'abord touché aussi
puis j'ai commencé à faire de la pop
maisons plus tard puis c'était mettons
exemple je suis arrivée au cégep quand
tu es au secondaire
on était comme les deux ensemble avec
nécessairement on était comme dans les
meilleurs de la gang de chant de acardi
mettons deux de l'école on était comme
ça
j'espère que tu te tromper
j'ai pas mis le un coup de j'avais
tellement de croûtes à manger en terme
de parce que dans le thème de théorie
musicale nous on a envie de pas mal mais
tiens-moi à ce moment-là j'avais pas
entendu des bonnes habitudes vocales
j'avais épinglé vraiment des mauvais
réflexes j'avais des nodules en fait là
j'arrivais devant des chanteuses
incroyables qui avaient des des grandes
facultés vocales de fou puis il y avait
pas de problème de santé vocale c'est
moi la santé vocale c'est vraiment un
enjeu puis j'ai vraiment passé ma
princesse je broyais toutes les semaines
donc c'est terrible puis je me disais
vraiment genre je m'en veux je pensais
vraiment pas que j'allais te faire
parce que j'avais l'impression que ma
voix c'est trop un enjeu c'est trop top
chanter pas en sens que c'était puis de
pas perdre la voix qu'est-ce que ça
craque pas que genre j'avais tellement
de rattrapages à faire à ce niveau-là
que fait que ces années-là je travaille
à mon lit mais j'avais c'était vraiment
un bon coup d'humilité là
des classes d'ensemble c'est quand tu
présentes tes pièces devant tes amis si
présente
amis qui ont des commentaires puis qui
notent les commentaires c'est des
commentaires constructifs mettons que
c'est vraiment
j'ai 17 ans le chant maintenant puis ça
va pas si mal que ça puis j'étais hyper
j'avais un track de fou à ce moment-là
après piste les trois éléments équitori
regardent et les 3e année on les
trouvait dans le meilleur puis non non
j'ai vraiment travaillé au cégep si
jamais travaillé de même puis ça allait
vraiment bien c'est des feux de base
mais c'est sûr que ce à avoir
l'impression en fait d'avoir un peu
comme
ça a été je pense pas que je chanterai
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai il y a trop
fallu que j'apprenne des bases de
techniques puis je chanterai pas à
toutes les semaines sinon ça marcherait
pas pendant toute la c'est ça c'est un
affaire la voix ça se travaille vraiment
dans le fond oui
c'est sûr ça c'est sûr ça s'entraîne
puis ça s'apprend à bien l'utiliser pour
justement pas se faire mal ou genre pas
perdre la voix mais c'est pas tout le
monde qui a une belle voix
sonne tu mets ton moi je pourrais
travailler fort sur genre je pourrais
travailler fort sur comme être capable
de pas me laisser pas perdre la voix
ma santé vocale comme tu dis mais je
pense pas que ça amélioré la tonalité de
ma voix qui chante là
c'est sûr que de la génétique dans la
voile mettons là c'est sûr que après ça
prend des techniques tu peux la prendre
genre l'utiliser de comme différentes
façons mais tu sais il y a du monde qui
parle dans même mais c'est ça
exactement c'est qu'on a tous nos
attracteurs naturels tu sais c'est comme
naturellement tu as une tendance à
parler d'une certaine façon moins
naturellement avant j'avais tendance à
parler vraiment comme ça je poussais
beaucoup d'heures c'est comme je sais
pas ça parle fort chez nous je pense
c'est un garçon excuse-moi parce que il
fallait vraiment que je change dans le
sens que je comprends ce que tu veux
dire c'est vrai qu'on est pas
probablement des prédispositions mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un travail
qu'on peut faire pour juste changer ce
que naturellement de tendance à faire
prendre des meilleures pliés c'est sûr
que tu serais capable quand même de
chanter
après ça moi je pense que
[Musique]
qui ont pas des grandes voix mais c'est
leur créativité c'est de la manière qui
l'utilise qui rend c'est intéressant
puis même je pense que des gens qui ont
des voix mettons pas
qui on est pas particulière qui on les
voit singulière ça devient même si c'est
pas une voix qui est esthétiquement
mettons dans les canons de ce qui est
une belle une grande voix si je trouve
la manière de l'utiliser c'est ce qui
peut faire à force je comprends je
comprends ce que tu dis tu comprends ce
que tu dis par contre
mettons qu'on prend l'aspect génétique
qu'on fait un parallèle qui va essayer
de construire l'avion en vol qui est
pour pour lundi mon ma métaphore
maintenant tu prends le concept de
beauté là physique on peut dire qu'il y
a pauvreté universelle il y a des codes
de symétrie ou est-ce que les gens ont
intégrés de faire des études pour dire
ce serait quoi une beauté universelle tu
sais où est-ce que là comme le
stéréotype même de une personne qui
serait belle on serait capable de la
générer par et puis dire ça c'est ce qui
crée l'attraction je sais pas si ça se
calcule autant que ça aussi c'est juste
comme des sociaux
culturels non mais moi je pense que il y
a un visage qui crée l'attirance j'avais
plus j'avais vu ça passera
la symétrie du visage je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui a été étudié là ça
peut être je veux dire ça peut être
plusieurs types de visages mais je sais
que la symétrie du visage est quelque
chose qui est comme reconnu puis mettons
qu'on regarde pas Brad Pitt je pense que
universellement les gens le trouvent
beau puis je pense que tout le monde
s'entend pour dire que Brad Pitt il est
beau maintenant qu'on a ce concept là
universel puis qu'on l'applique au
chantier des grandes voix les belles
voix le qu'on considère comme grande et
belle fait que mettons quelqu'un Céline
Dion une grande voie qui chante bien
tout le monde je pense va dire c'est une
belle voix
[Musique]
j'adore vraiment mais on dirait que je
me dis ben il est quand même beaucoup de
monde qui mettent en ce temps-là ça leur
parle pas pendant toute la vie comme ça
on a envie puis c'est malade sur les
chansons je sais pas à quel point je
comprends pour le grand public dont il y
a des trucs peut-être je sais pas ce
matin où est-ce que je vais en venir
avec ça c'est comme il y a des voix que
tout le monde va faire oui genre ça
c'est une grande voie ça peut pas être
mon affaire à moi peut-être que j'aime
pas ça c'est peut-être moi j'aime pas
ces chansons j'aime pas sa voix sauf que
je reconnais que il y a une grande voix
Brad Pitt c'est pas mon genre on va
reconnaître que Brad Pitt est un est une
belle personne vous comprenez ce que je
veux dire moi je comprends des voix qui
met ton techniquement c'est difficile à
atteindre puis ce qui est impressionnant
qui sont vraiment pile poil sur les
notes puis qui sont irradent jamais les
notes qui sont tout le temps genre super
souvent mettons c'est voila dont tu
parles qui mettent en fait l'exercice de
penser c'est voilà donc tu parles c'est
souvent des voix qui vont qui vont
pousser des notes hautes forts c'est
c'est
quelque chose que le commun des Martel
est pas capable de faire c'est ça qui
fait qui t'impressionnant c'est que ça
sort la norme c'est un petit groupe
select des personnes sont capables de
faire ça mais donc je pense que c'est ça
c'est comme quelqu'un qui quelqu'un qui
est fucking
on va on va reconnaître que ça demande
du travail puis que la difficulté
la discipline après ça c'est pas tout le
monde qui trouve ça beau tu sais
reconnaître les prouesses vocales les
facultés mettons la technique la virtuce
c'est mais après on le sentiment
c'est ça la question est-ce que ça crée
une émotion est-ce que je trouve ça beau
moi Céline ça peut me créer une émotion
en fait
des voix considérées comme étant belle
qui vont pas créer une émotion et vice
versa des voix justement c'est des voix
plus fragiles les voix plus atypiques
qui peuvent m'écrire toutes sortes
d'émotions
tout à fait mais je commence que ce que
tu
mais je pense que ça peut chanter
il y a tellement
oui il y a des il y a quelques gens le
loups
en même temps il y a vraiment une voix
unique
ce qui existe pas ça puis moi je pense
pas que j'aurai une voix unique qui
existe pas je pense j'aurais juste que
j'aurai une voix de quelqu'un qui chante
qui fait quand même toi tu es pas tu ne
l'as pas vraiment là
il est plus ce que ce que fait sa
carrière c'est plus ces textes que sa
voix 100%
que tu prends des trucs je sais pas
c'est peut-être maintenant la musique
classique ou certains types de musique
qui mettons la voix
vaut vraiment faire en sorte que qui va
définir un peu
la performance ton succès mettons
mais en chanson c'est c'est 90% la
créativité
tout ce que vous dites on comprend
vraiment sauf que je suis persuadé que
moi avec les textes de Jean Leloup ça
fonctionne
il y en a plein qui a créé puis qui
voudra peut-être commencer
beaucoup de génétiques dans ce qui est
ce que je voulais dire tantôt par
rapport au visage pour la symétrie c'est
qu'il y a des trucs qui on est capable
de calculer comment on perçoit certaines
affaires comment il y a des choses dans
la symétrie du visage qui nous attire ou
non puis je suis sûr que la même chose
dans les fréquences d'une voix je
persuadé que ça mais ça se peut mais moi
je pense que mon poste c'est que si un
moment donné tu avais un élan tu avais
l'appel de l'écriture et d'un projet
artistique et que au final tu démontré
mais dans des compétences puis un talent
d'en écrire des tonnes puisque tu
travailles ta voix puis que ta voix
serait comme elle est puis que j'ai
jamais entendu en chantant d'ailleurs à
mon état ça donnerait mais
si ce que ça fait partie de ta promotion
c'est ce que ça parle aux gens ça parle
aux gens si je pense que puis après mais
oui comme le fait il y a des
prédispositions j'ai l'impression que je
pourrais jamais chanter parce que j'ai
mes limites près des gens qui disent non
c'est pareil on peut tout pratiquer mais
moi j'ai cette impression d'une certaine
façon en fait je suis d'accord avec toi
mais c'est vraiment je suis sorti de
l'université en ayant passé tellement
d'années justement être plus dans la
technique plus à travailler ma pratique
vocale parce que plus après c'est
mettons puis quand j'ai commencé à faire
mon projet j'ai l'impression que j'ai
mis ça de côté je me dis juste concentré
sur je sais pas mais ce qui m'a donné
bonne j'ai vraiment mon interprétation
même la performance la scène puis à mon
avis j'ai l'impression que je m'en SCRL
c'est comment chanter puis même que un
certain point j'étais comme j'ai écouté
des enregistrements que j'avais fait un
choix je suis dans mes chantiers made on
dirait que j'ai quasiment c'est pas que
c'est je voudrais c'est important pour
moi de de chanter de mieux que je peux
si je fais attention à ça dans mes shows
ça fait partie de ce que j'ai cette
faire mais il y a des moments que il y a
des trucs qui prennent le dessus je sais
pas comment ça y est
des fois ça me dérange pas d'entendre
quelqu'un d'un show puis que la personne
en soit un peu à côté quand il se passe
quelque chose de vraiment fort quand
même puis c'est pas 100% d'accord avec
ça parce que même je veux dire dans une
proposition tu peux accepter les
erreurs puis qui font partie même la
proposition c'est vraiment les accepter
mais c'est le meilleur exemple de ça
normalement c'est le meilleur exemple de
ça par contre
c'est pas tout le monde qui peut faire
ça moi c'est plutôt ça mon point c'est
le moment
incroyablement unique et comme jamais
entendu
[Musique]
l'imperfection même le fait qu'il faut
aussi ça peut
être un choix améliorer ça peut ça peut
ça peut
ça peut augmenter la trait vers quelque
chose
mettez puis la musique
la musique c'est pas juste la musique
c'est aussi qu'est ce que ça représente
quelle valeur sa véhicule même si tout
ça était souvent inconscient mais tout
le monde écouter pas juste Nirvana
Nirvana Nirvana pour la voix tu es
combien tu sais c'est tout ce que ce
bandel le mouvement représenté à
l'époque où c'est arrivé c'est un
courant c'est c'est des valeurs c'est
des c'est une émotion c'est un c'est un
catalyseur de frustration peut-être ou
de toutes sortes de choses c'est un
contre-courant contre culture à ce qui
se faisait avant
rejet de titre rébellion envers les
parents ou envers tout ça en même temps
qui fait que qu'un groupe marche le
titre c'est
impossible à calculer une
d'éléments qui qui vient faire que ça ça
va toucher une corde chez quelqu'un
ça dépasse la voix ça dépasse
[Musique]
tout pour dire que en plus tout un
bagarre dans une écriture tu es capable
d'écrire tu sais
convaincu que si tu disais j'ai le goût
d'écrire des tonnes peut-être que
pendant que
mais ce qui contient de le faire pendant
un moment puis tu disais vraiment je
vais m'améliorer à ça comme tu veux
t'améliorer en cours sur comme tu veux
t'améliorer
éventuellement t'écrire des wonton avec
ta voix je suis sûr je sais pas
moi
je suis d'accord avec ça que je suis pas
sûr de ça
que je me projette dans genre
éventuellement je serai un athlète de
natation professionnelle je me dis je
pense pas mais c'est différent
et peut-être que tu as commenté mettons
peut-être que tu aurais commencé trop
tard pour devenir assez bon
éventuellement pour toucher des gens
peut-être mais en même temps
j'ai commencé j'ai commencé à manger à 5
ans en me disant je vais être athlète
olympique je ne suis jamais devenu
oui tu comprends il y en a qui sont
devenus ici il y en a qui ont commencé à
14 ans de manger puis ils sont devenus
que j'ai l'impression que ça vient aussi
de sites pas cette curieux mais donc tu
veux faire ça mais d'une façon super
mécanique
de faire les choses de façon cérébrale
c'est une façon de faire aussi puis ça
peut donner quelque chose de bon mais si
c'est ça c'est mécanique ça vient quand
même pas d'un appel de créativité d'une
genre de sensibilité à ce qui est comme
des choses dans les traites
personnalités j'imagine je sais pas
j'avoue que il y a du monde qui vont
faire ça toute leur vie qui vont essayer
puis essayer parmi ça marche pas j'avoue
que ça je pense que si j'essaie toute ma
vie exemple d'être mécanicienne manger
une répare des chars dans le sens que je
pense que écoute peut-être qu'un jour le
je serai une mécanicienne la meilleure
au monde c'est un nom en fait ça arrive
de devenir vraiment une bonne
mécanicienne
mécaniquement après quelque chose de
mécanique
il y a quand même des des outils mettons
ça s'apprend aussi écrire des tonnes il
y a un aspect un aspect viscéral et
motif mais il y a quand même des
techniques
en fait c'est accessible tout le temps
peut cesser à ça mais c'est je pense
vraiment pour sentir que que
tu le sens que il y a des gens ça se
passe
il y a des gens qui ont c'est une
portion de charisme là-dedans il y a une
portion de de
plein de facteurs juste comme des du
monde qui ont juste comme de quoi de
leur véhicule ou juste un million de
quoi dire puis d'autres moins
que c'est pas nécessairement tout le
monde qui veut faire ce qui travaille
fort il faut rester à le faire je pense
que toi tu pourrais
m'appliquer parce que mettons je sais
que dans mon parcours université j'ai
écrit des textes qui étaient à mon avis
encore aujourd'hui je les relis puis je
les trouve vraiment bon genre je suis
capable de d'admettre ça sachez qu'en
écriture capable de le faire mon point
c'est que je pense pas que je serais
capable avec ma voix d'aller rejoindre
les gens pour porter ses textes-là parce
que ça prend un rôle package tu as du
monde qui ont une voix qui prenait les
textes des autres pour aller les porter
parce que les gens qui écrivent des
textes qui ont pas la voix pour porter
les textes puis inversement il y a des
gens qui qui ont pas nécessairement la
voix pour porter des textes mais qui où
l'inverse de ce que je disais on
comprend ce que je veux dire que moi
c'est plus ça mon point et puis moi je
pense qu'il y a quand même un aspect
quand peut-être qu'on calcule pas dans
les récepteurs de comment on est capable
de percevoir ce qui est bon puis les
textes viennent aussi jouer ce qui nous
touche c'est individuel effectivement tu
peux tu peux te faire toucher par
quelque chose que quelqu'un ça ne touche
pas du tout mais je pense quand même que
dans la voie dans l'instrument il y a
quelque chose qu'une guide peut sonner
le cul tout le monde va faire ça le
snare de c'est intéressant
universellement ça sonne le cul puis il
y a personne qui fait genre un an moi
j'aime ça ce sont là de cacan de
personnes encore une affaire aussi de
courant puis de mode là
tout le monde dit
des fois c'est genre de risque que tu
dis mettons
les décisions qui sont un peu connes
mais quand on se dit soit le monde
trouve ça malade
que tu prends tes autres sont dit les
snare
normalement c'est tout ce que tu
voudrais pas on va faire ça puis là ça a
pas marché non mais ça aurait pu marcher
aussi des semaines dans un état de
d'ouverture puis de
sauter c'est une croyance aussi mettons
le dans le sens que il y a quelque chose
je comprends que des référents pieds
ça s'apprend puis
je sais pas comment dire comme je suis
d'accord avec toi donc en fait genre je
pense que des fois ça fait partie de
ceux de se dire ok là ce que je pense
absolument qu'ils bon ce que je pense à
tout le monde qui m'investre c'est
correct des fois de prendre juste un
exemple de remettre ça en question puis
d'essayer de parce que quand des choses
qui sont nées de ça c'est important
de quelque chose qui est en fait tout le
monde a ici rapport même dans il y a des
accords
on n'aimait pas
la musique au défunt on décide si on
aime ça on n'aime pas ça et puis c'est
très
identiteur la musique qu'est-ce que tu
décides d'aimer c'est un peu un reflet
de quitter puis de quel genre de quel
genre de groupe tu vas appartenir c'est
tout ça et subconscient mais il existe
le mettons
moi Britney Spears mettons quand que
j'avais 10 ans puis que mon grand frère
me disait ce qui est bon c'est du punk
je vais écouter du punk puis ça c'est
bon mini Spears
aujourd'hui j'écoute Baby One More Time
je fais mes hit c'est débile
il y a les courants qui partent qui
reviennent c'est mettons
je sais pas la musique à Lady Gaga
mettons Poker Face là ça a été vraiment
big dans une certaine fin 2000 mettons
aujourd'hui plus vraiment personne fait
ça parce que là ça a été fait mais bleu
assez pas longtemps pour que ça soit
dans un creux de vagues que c'est pas
cool il va avoir un creux de vague
bientôt que tout le monde va faire de la
musique Gaga puis ça ça revient ça pas
puisqu'on trouve beau qu'on trouve pas
beau qu'on trouve bon qu'on trouve pas
bon sans constante évolution puis mais
pas longtemps la musique du début des
années 2000 on écoutait c'est bon on
trouvait ça quand même à chier puis je
serai là maintenant j'écoute
mais puis dans ce cas même pas juste
c'est pas sarcasse juste mais j'écoute
la prod je trouve ça incroyable
absolument incroyable c'est encore à ce
jour mais quand même j'ai l'impression
quand même que peut-être mettons parce
que moi
adolescente j'écoutais ça puis je
m'identifié plus à ça
les années 80 aussi à mon avis c'était
complètement je veux dire c'est on en
veut plus on veut plus les temps des
années 80 puis 2 semaines plus de 6 des
années 80 c'est la vague de il y a des
inquiétudeurs partout puis-je vous dire
ça revient foule puis mais c'est sûr que
c'est des courammes c'est super danseur
quand tu as d'autres identification en
plus est-ce que est-ce que tu aimes pas
qu'est-ce que tu aimes c'est ça fait
partie de ça aussi là moi j'ai tout le
temps part on dirait de
identifie déjà ce qui se faisait plus en
a évolue vite au sein même temps de ce
qui se fait dans la musique kebab
exemple et c'est rapidement
je fais mon son je m'en fous de ce qui
se passe en ce moment je veux dire ça
risque inconscient j'écoute la musique
qui se fait puis il y a un son en ce
moment qui fait probablement puis qu'on
veut écouter on le voit déjà mais
écoutez ça dans 10 ans puis on va voir à
qui ça c'était comme
début de début d'essayer 2020
en même temps tu peux pas te sortir de
ça dans le sens que c'est comme ça puis
c'est pas grave mais on dirait que des
fois je mais ça me gosse c'est quand on
écoute quelque chose pendant tout le
temps de référence temporelle ça
m'énerve tellement on dirait que ça
enferme toute la tonne dans une dans
quelque chose
vouloir sonner ses ventes
un peu à gauche à droite des influences
au lieu de juste comme
[Musique]
qui parle de tel sujet c'est juste comme
c'est ça dans l'air puis ça arrive puis
bon tout le monde il a même des en même
temps ça ça arrive aussi
[Musique]
toute la musique du monde existe déjà
tout fait juste
tu fais juste à m'emmener dans notre
pays une puis genre là
la métropole
c'est toi ton canal ton canals
j'aimerais tellement ça écrit comme des
personnes j'aimerais tellement ça
genre avoir autant de
paramètres qui nous inspirent de
d'autres artistes ça sera jamais sûr aux
gens ça sera jamais
c'est tu peux pas faire comme comme
quelqu'un d'autre tout le temps
ton delivery tout le temps rester de
même puis j'ai l'impression toute ta vie
c'est quand même que j'ai peur de me
répéter devant ce que je dis dans ce que
je compose j'ai l'impression que
je vois tout le temps d'une façon
différente avec une perception
différente avec une expérience
une maturité de plus je sais pas mais
j'ai l'impression qu'on sent qu'on s'en
sort pas que ça fait un peu raison mon
enfer mais c'est pas c'est juste ça fait
partie de ton
habite toute ta vie là
il y a des choses qui vont pour toujours
faire partie de ton ton lexique
d'émotion si on l'exemple de Daniel
Bélanger ça fait 30 ans que je chante
sur la solitude c'est essentiellement
différente qu'il disait en 93 sauf que
il dit en parle encore là
tout le monde mais j'ai des feelings qui
reviennent de mon secondaire encore
maintenant que j'ai exactement le même
feeling espèce de même mélancolique
j'avais au secondaire dans certains
moments qui étaient les moments que
j'étais le plus créatif que j'écrivais
le plus ben je ressens encore pareil ces
moments-là une fréquence qui est
aussi fréquente que quand j'avais 15 ans
puis que je vais sur ma ressentir toute
ma vie jusqu'à ce que je sois vieux je
pense qu'on a toute une coupe de thèmes
majeurs mettons de nos vies qui vont
tout le temps comme nous suivre puis qui
est artiste qui vont comme ça
probablement aussi que ça c'est à ces
moments-là mettons quand il revienne en
force que tu redeviens créatif
un certain moment dans ta vie de façon
périodique j'ai l'impression mais si
c'est un beau vouloir c'est de partir de
il y a des choses que ça va tout le
temps rester là je sais pas pourquoi
[Musique]
plus large en terme de traitées
qui vont suivre des choses qui vont
évoluer puis c'est correct ça fait
partie de moi puis c'est pas une affaire
de je suis condamné à ça je changerai
jamais c'est pas du tout ça mais c'est
juste un moment donné tu sais je veux
dire c'est on ne bagage c'est correct
exacter il faut continuer à vouloir
s'améliorer en tant que personne en tant
qu'individu sur plusieurs aspects sauf
que on est qui on est
assez tôt dans notre existence
il faut le trouver il faut le savoir
surtout si tu veux être un artiste je
pense c'est quitter c'est ça qui fait de
ta force puis ta différence puis des
fois le piège de
quelqu'un qui va commencer peut-être à
mettons à créer des tonnes c'est
d'essayer d'être quelqu'un d'autre de
voir au Québec ça j'aime ça ou ça ça
fonctionne je vais essayer d'être ce
mais
tu seras jamais
parce que ce sera jamais en phase avec
toi quitter puisque tu fais du temps
avoir un décalage puis quand un décalage
que je pense que
l'auditeur ou
il sentent et comme quelque chose qui
fonctionne pas puis qui fait que ça
marche pas
se connaître soi-même c'est comme un peu
le
c'est comme la base c'est là aussi la
chose la plus importante ça va qu'est-ce
qui fait toi qui fait que tu es unique
on les voit comme des défauts le
longtemps j'ai vu puis autant dans le
point de vue humain mais musicalement si
je parlais ma voix tantôt moi ça a été
souvent un genre de blocage de comédie
trucs je pourrai pas chanter des trucs
je vais tout le temps avoir plus de
misère avec d'autres personnes à faire
puis après ça fait partie de qui je suis
il y a des moments que chante d'une
certaine façon je me dis genre en ce
moment ça va tout le temps évoluer mais
c'est ce que j'ai à proposer puis ça
fait partie de moi puis même humaine
c'est pas naissant que c'était va partir
de ma vie c'est que la façon la place
qu'apprend dans ma vie à l'évolu puis il
y a différentes puis des fois ça c'est
une de mes forces puis des choses des
fois c'est c'est comme ça ça va changer
puis je vais pas être très épais même à
faire mais je veux dire si
on dirait moi je suis dans mon chemin
les plus
délivrante
l'acceptance de comme certaines affaires
c'est un gros travail de faire comme il
y a des affaires que envers toi-même que
tu contrôles pas envers les autres que
tu contrôles pas de juste faire genre
[Musique]
dans ma vie
ça fait du bien en tabarnant faut que tu
apprennes à faire sur toi direct
comme ça puis je peux essayer de
m'améliorer encore mais ça ce trait là
il va être là il va être là pour le
reste de ma vie je peux travailler
dessus je peux essayer de l'améliorer
sauf que quand je rencontre quelqu'un je
sais que je vois comme ça puis je sais
que ça va être impossible de le changer
à un point complètement complet je vais
pouvoir enlever des affaires contrôler
des trucs mais ça ça va être là une fois
tu acceptes ça arrive avec ça c'est moi
à ma plaine j'imagine c'est la même
chose quand tu as une offre artistique
c'est ça c'est moi ma plaine conscience
ou ce que j'en suis maintenant dans mes
affaires
c'est vraiment libératoire de dire ça
puis
que l'autre personne avec toutes les
informations ou que l'autre personne ou
que le public peu importe avec toutes
les informations
de toi à 100% quitter là au moment où
est-ce que tu le dis puis c'est le fun
pour toi c'est le fond de savoir que
l'autre personne les obsters ont cette
information-là piquez ils savent
Facebook de toute façon n'ayant mes amis
normalement qui me dit il y a 30 ans
puis il venait d'avoir envie d'être
comme j'ai réalisé qu'il y avait
tellement
il me disait j'ai réalisé encore
tellement de choses à apprendre et
tellement de choses que je m'intrigue
pas dans ma vie ensemble j'ai tellement
de ischious mais je pense que
j'ai pas compris j'ai pas fait garanti
je pense que je suis en plein cœur de ma
jeune viaduc puis je suis vraiment genre
je suis en train d'essayer de
de faire ma place à dedans puis il dit
je trouve ça tellement haute j'ai
tellement de choses à apprendre encore
il trouvait ça full stimulant et d'ici
passionnant c'est toute ma vie mettons
j'ai ça
[Musique]
et ça a été un genre de soulagement il
me dit ça puis je serais et moi je vois
ça juste comme une lutte c'est vrai que
je vois tellement souvent qu'est-ce qui
fonctionne pas dans la vie
en termes de
je pense que j'ai l'air d'avoir de la
gratitude pour ce que j'ai mais c'est de
ce qui fonctionne pas des fois dans
Comment je suis dans mes réflexes dans
dans ma façon des fois de puis lui c'est
juste comme un c'était
juste faire du chemin tu sais pas
t'apporter puis je trouvais ça on dirait
qu'il y avait quand même
oui et c'est normal puis juste comme tu
disais le moment où tu dis un comme en
ce moment j'aime boy 100% que je suis
seul pour le moment ça va être aussi
être en apprentissage encore
mais tu dépasses déjà là où tu étais
quand justement dans le sens que c'est
pas t'enfermé là-dedans c'est juste du
chemin être comme prendre plus
possession de de quitter ils avaient
fait comme aussi que ça fait du bien
déjà je sais pas je suis déjà de savoir
déjà d'avoir la lucidité de savoir
commenter
ces pots c'est pas si facile puis c'est
pas tout le monde qui est rendu ne
serait-ce qu'à cet appel
d'avoir fait cette introspection là j'ai
ça sur tel trait tel très très
bon puis genre comme ça puissant
l'inverse mais
c'est sûr la connaissance comme genre le
premier étage l'acceptation puis après
ça c'est pas non plus parce que tu en
acceptation
que tu es pas en travail non mais non
mais oui on voit que
moi ça dans ce que je fais dans ma vie
en ce moment parce que dans un prix
tellement du temps d'assumer que je
voulais faire ça d'assumer que j'avais
même une ambition
artistique puis que je voulais faire ça
comme métier on dirait que c'est comme
pour moi de c'était je sais pas j'étais
pas à l'aise avec la place que ça me
demandait de prendre de plus être
incohérence mais
dans la dans la bienveillance avec moi
ça me fait dans la bienveillance avec le
genre de 1 c'est correct qui était
désirs existent puis que tu peux faire
ça tu as le droit de vouloir puis
pendant le moment de ma vie comme étant
et c'est quoi tes rêves c'est mignon des
projets dans des prochaines années et
puis c'est je sais pas tiens au jour le
jour puis ça fait partie de moi aussi
mais j'osais pas le dire en fait c'est
même plus que j'ose pas dire j'osais pas
me permettre d'y penser parce que ça
impliquait trop de je peux pas me
tromper mais ton si je dis ça il faut
comme que je le fasse faut comme il y
avait quelque chose avec un genre de
1h30
d'être trop dans c'est important de
l'humilité c'est important de pas trop
qui bien en fait là le fameux KEB qui
je suis comme mais non mais ça me tente
tellement de faire ça ça me tend
tellement de tel projet tel voyage de la
faire puis même encore le j'ai une drôle
de relation
au plaisir puis au par exemple
je me permets justement que ce désires
là puis rêve là existent parce que c'est
comme tout le temps un genre de fringues
non mais là pas trop parce que il paraît
quelque chose mais pas trop parce que
faire attention c'était pas calme-toi la
grosse tête et quelque chose dans je
trouve ça complique je trouve que je
parle de ça mais en ce que c'est
vraiment super intéressant
verbaliser tes objectifs c'est des
choses les plus difficiles parce que ça
devient
ça devient vrai comme tu dis tu sais ça
vient rire du tout au tout sauf quand
même temps si tu es pas capable des
verbaliser comment tu penses être
capable des atteindre
tu t'autorises pas tu t'autorises pas la
permission de verbaliser où est-ce que
tu vas être c'est quoi tes ambitions
c'est quoi tes objectifs là je dis pas
je dois être multimilliardaire Ilona
mais mettons que tu si c'est ça ton
affaire
bonne chance hein mais tu peux le
verbaliser aussi si vraiment ça
t'intéresse sauf que je trouve que de se
permettre justement de s'autoriser à
dire clairement c'est quoi tes ambitions
c'est le début de la patente
c'est pas nécessairement écraser celle
des autres c'est pas parce que tu te
permets de ouais j'ai envie de plus
grand puis de plus gros que je suis
nécessairement complètement en train de
virer folle puis en train de te dire
tout le monde comme je sais pas si j'ose
a pris aussi
vouloir riches plus de monde mettons
avec ton art
c'est beau dans le sens que c'est
vouloir
s'échange-là puis de t'y mettons
vouloir être connu c'est comme si il y a
vraiment une distinction entre
vouloir faire de quoi puis toucher du
monde puis tu sais peut-être faire une
petite différence pour le plus de monde
possible puis mettons
ça peut être perçu comme juste comme ah
ben je veux avoir plus plus connu plus
si plus mais tu sais c'est plus pur
c'est plus beau que juste comme vouloir
avoir les yeux sur sur moi
la progression mettons
juste dans la dernière année entre le
lancement de l'album qui était là
d'ailleurs au ministère qui était débile
qui était à ce moment-là le plus gros
show mettons en billetterie qu'on avait
fait
moi j'étais complètement comme flaber
gastrique comme 200 personnes là de 5
personnes
dans les heures mais qui n'existait pas
puis qu'on a comme piocher là-dessus
travailler tu sais comme poli ceux
pendant tellement longtemps ça sort plus
ça intéresse le monde ça les touche puis
genre ça leur procure des du plaisir ou
de les toutes sortes d'émotions qui
après ça d'autres et encore plus de
monde il y a encore plus de monde qui
chante les tunes qui connaissent les
paroles
c'est un feeling quand même incroyable
c'est pas juste des comme ainsi qu'on
est là ça marche le projet c'est comme
eh on partage quelque chose puis
les gens aiment ça aurait tendance
à ce jour c'est un des c'était fou
je pense pas qu'en terme je pense pas
que mes musicalement c'est notre
meilleur choix c'était genre on a promis
la tournée clairement c'était pas le
meilleur choix au monde et pour nous
c'est justement comme tu dis voir la
première fois que il y avait des gens
qui chantaient des paroles c'est une
première fois puis la première année où
tu sors en album c'est que des premières
fois puis les premières fois vous comme
les
c'est de tout le temps essayer de
de le vivre pleinement parce que tu en
es pas conscient nécessairement que
c'est comme mais ça réarrivera plus là
si je veux dire tu étais à ce moment-là
juste une fois dans ta vie puis même
c'est des moments où que ça a été
vertigineux si justement d'avoir ça de
lui en gros aussi en ben c'est sûr que
ça aide à
l'accueillir moi j'ai trouvé ça dur des
buts je comprends encore que si je veux
dire c'est vraiment pas c'est juste que
pour moi c'est c'est beaucoup à la fois
disque le soir maintenant je suis pas
j'ai pas j'ai pas sur un nuage mettons
le soir j'ai fait j'ai fait une crise
d'angoisse j'étais angoissée puis
j'étais puis j'étais ça change faut que
ça change rien c'est une reconnaissance
mais c'est finalement
mais il y avait quelque chose dans dans
comprendre ce qui arrivait puis avoir
l'impression que
un vertige de pas capable des fois être
juste un c'est vraiment un de prendre
complètement ce qui m'arrivait puis avec
le recul je suis déçu des fois de pas
d'être tout le temps rester en mode le
but c'est d'altérateur d'être vraiment
grande et puis de pas commencer à partir
sur une chair de genre m'emballe avec ça
puis je suis content de l'avoir fait à
certains moments parce que je me dis que
je reste une personne je pense très
terre à terre par rapport à ses affaires
là puis dans les moments moins bon parce
que si on ennuie les choses dans ton
équipe ça allait peut-être
[Rires]
de reconnaissance d'être capable de
comme juste cet en réception de
l'accepter ah j'ai trouvé c'est
dur puis en même temps c'est fou tu es
qui sur ça parce que tu sais il y a une
affaire ça empêche pas que je suis full
reconnaissant vous voyez c'est pas
c'est mais si on reparle à ce moment-là
puis je me disais non c'est sûr que dans
ma vie le show militaire ou la première
fois que ça s'est passé ça va être
encore dans les top moment parce que
même c'est de faire plus grande que ça
qui sont arrivés qui sont qui sont à
venir
mais c'est ça je sais pas ça a une
valeur qui
quand tu écrivais le deuxième le premier
album
c'était comme c'était la pandémie
puisqu'il y avait plein de j'ai
l'impression dans ta vie de
montagne russe le matin
piloter maintenant
[Musique]
si tu vis des affaires mais ça va bien
ensemble je pense en général tu parles
de manquer de juice de côté
puis genre tu es comme moi j'ai
l'impression que je suis tout le temps
une personne tourmentée puis qui
s'arrange pour vivre si ça gosse mais
dans ce que je vis mes émotions tout le
temps intensément puis j'ai pour réagis
cette réflexion là dernièrement je me
suis dit est-ce que des fois je me mets
dans des situations pour être
mélancolique pour être un peu plus
est-ce que je vais chercher des fois ce
genre de
d'intensité pour avoir de quoi
dire propre des poètes maudits
d'existence misérable juste pour pouvoir
écrire sur son existence misérable
c'était ça finalement
je pense pas que c'est le cas mais non
c'est sûr mais j'ai mais en même temps
il y a quand même de quoi dans c'est oui
c'est vivre des montagnes russes mais
c'était le fait d'avoir énormément de
temps
puis bon pas grand chose à faire mais du
temps pour pour
on fait des choses pour le premier album
tu sais j'ai l'impression outre le fait
de genre je vais laisser mon chum demain
parce que ça me tente d'écrire un
incident album
je sais pas mais il faut comme ou un fou
comme je disais dans ton genre de
coupure aussi puis le temps de vivre des
études ça peut être une expérience quand
même mais c'est un classique mais ça
pourrait être parti en voyage c'est pas
nécessairement seul c'est aussi des
juste prendre le temps de
ce qui se passe à l'extérieur parce que
sinon
exactement
sa vision du voyage de pour un travail
de ce que j'ai vu son adresse peu
importe puis il m'avait répondu un
espèce de bloc paragraphe sans
ponctuation
genre un vrai poète genre
un bloc de flow of the SNES sur sa
vision du voyage puis à travers plein
d'affaires vraiment
disjoncter dans ce paraphe là il y avait
un truc qui disait quand je pars je pars
pour
revenir avec en déconstruisant ma vision
de ma vie donc pour avoir une nouvelle
vision sur ma propre existence fait que
lui son voyage ils étaient pas pour
aller voir dans d'autres pays et puis
expérimenter d'autres d'autres cultures
c'était pour briser la façon avec
laquelle il doit être il voyait sa
propre existence quand il revenait ici
fait qui partent en voyage sa propre
existence puis elle voyait dans un
filtre différent puis là l'inspiration
lui revenait bref
[Musique]
que tu fais des trucs intenses ou que tu
es complètement dans un autre univers
complètement tu te rends compte du
Nouveau Monde
moi c'est il y a une certaine fois que
je suis revenu puis que j'étais comme je
t'ai tellement c'est peut-être classé
aussi
débutant le Georges voyage rien compris
ici on est tellement dans un cadre
non mais c'est cliché
mais c'est cliché mais ça fait ça pareil
j'ai appris non mais
c'est vrai
mais je vous emmène genre j'ai pas tant
j'ai full voyage dans ma vie mais
beaucoup plus pour la musique donc pour
le travail même quand j'étais jeune
c'était comme avec la chorale ou avec
mes parents mais comme un voyage de
vingtaine j'en ai pas vraiment fait en
fait pour mon propre fun puis si je sais
que des fois ça peut certainement être
un
un déclencheur peut-être c'est comme si
je me suis pas périmé tant de le faire
parce que justement j'ai beaucoup voyagé
et j'étais comme métier je vivais déjà
avec la musique au moins puis de on
négocie quand même dans un métier que
c'est top des fois de prévoir à l'avance
qui s'est 2 semaines là je m'en vais
c'est comme un gros engagement de mais
en fait faut le faire ça c'est vraiment
ce que je suis en train de me dire en ce
moment puis c'est coupure là oui mais je
sais ouais
je prends plus d'engagement à partir de
là
merci beaucoup c'était super le fun ça
m'a fait trop plaisir
des fois quand on s'entend pas sur un
choix puis il faut le débat
est-ce que c'est comment ça s'appelle
l'actrice qui appartient